alors la mitrailleuse surprise de walter
white oui la métaphore idéal de
l'expression que nous étudions
aujourd'hui dans le dernier épisode de
breaking bad
walter installe une mitrailleuse
autonome dans son coffre quand le
dispositif se met en marche elle tue
tous ses ennemis d'un seul coup
attention spoilers arrête tout le monde
a vu la série d'accords si mes souvenirs
sont exacts il s'agissait du deal
travailleuses m60 tout à fait
alors je crois qu'elle a un sacré punch
on devra les l'attesté nous mêmes pour
nous faire une idée je sens que ça va me
plaire
faisons le
donc le piège concocté par walter white
repose sur une mitrailleuse m60 attire
autonome caché dans le coffre de sa
voiture
mais le système qui l'a bricolé lui même
aurait-il pu résister à la puissance de
cette arme légendaire la m60 tir à une
cadence de cinq cent cinquante coups par
minute
ça fait beaucoup de plomb jamie et moi
allons faire plus ample connaissance
avec cette mitrailleuse au club de tir
chabot pour vérifier son recul et sa
puissance jenny m'a dit qu'il allait
amener la mitrailleuse
il doit être quelque part dans le coin
le sujet voici la mitrailleuse m60 elle
a été conçue dans les années 50 et
l'armée américaine s'en est servi jusque
dans les années 90 c'est la mitrailleuse
que l'on voit entre les mains des
soldats en hélicoptère dans tous les
documents d'époque de la guerre du
vietnam
ses larmes que walter a caché dans son
coffre
les miss duster ont une nouvelle fois
sorti l'artillerie lourde
mais est-elle trop puissante lp est-ce
vraiment une tonne tu vas sentir un
recul pour que walter et pull à monter
sur son dispositif maison allons-y pour
le découvrir
adam commence doucement au semi
automatique jantes le cran de sûreté
c'est parti dans 3 2 1
c'était cool je viens de tirer 45 bal
avec la n60 sincèrement le recul est
moins important que je l'aurais cru
mais le fait est qu'elle est très lourde
et qu'il y a beaucoup de mouvements mais
le support qu'on montera dans le coffre
devra pouvoir encaisser de grosses
vibrations pour la précision bien sûr
mais aussi pour une question de sécurité
le recul est plus faible que prévu ce
qui aurait tendance à valider le piège
de walter mais une fois les larmes à
puissance maximale cela va-t-il changer
ok ce parti
obtenir une amm 60 quand elles tirent en
continu c'est un peu comme essayé
d'immobiliser un serpent géant très en
colère j'ai déjà fait entre parenthèses
et ya bien un petit effet de recul dans
laxe de larmes mais c'est supportable
elle est assez maniable
jusqu'ici tout se passe bien mais pour
reproduire le mythe avec plus
d'exactitude
il leur faut une cible parfait et ce
n'est pas tout ok c'est parti cette
fois-ci jimmy va tirer 200 balles avec
la mitrailleuse posé sur son bon pied
3 2 1
il exploite la mitrailleuse à sa
capacité maximale de neuf balles par
seconde
le poids et la conception de larmes font
que le recul est étonnamment faible
surtout avec l'emploi du guêpier
l'utilisé depuis un support de fortune
n'est peut-être pas une exagération
hollywoodienne
ça doit faire mal à suivre
ado et jimmy sont sur un bateau
boum puis un invité de marque les
rejoint pour la reconstitution de
breaking bad c'est du costaud
ce qu'ils gagnent le créateur de
breaking bad